العلاقات بين رياض واشنطن هي يعني ما هي
ما هي يعني كويسه يعني فيها في في توتر في
العلاقه خاصه مع الحزب الديمقراطي والرئيس
بايدن
معامله معامله الرئيس بعيدا للسعوديه
الكلام اللي قال له
الطريقه اللي بيتكلم فيها عن السعوديه
وحتى سياساته اتجاه السعوديه وهي انه طلب
من السعوديه انه
الانتاج النفطي يزيد عندما يريد ان
يخفض من سعره اما لضرب ومحاربه روسيا او
لتحسين
الوضع الاقتصادي في امريكا لكي يفوز في
الانتخابات في امريكا يعني علاقته
بالسعوديه ما هي علاقه ما هي علاقه نديه
ما هي علاقه بل هي علاقه فيها نوع من
الاستعلاء فيها نوع من الاتجاه اتجاه
المملكه فا
بالاضافه الى ذلك ان كان بايدن او قبله
ترامب يعني
علاقتهم بالسعوديه تجاه امن الامن القومي
السعودي ما هو يعني ما في ضمانات عندما
ضربت ايران مثلا في سبتمبر 2019 المنشات
النفطيه في السعوديه لم ياتي ترامبو يدافع
لم يفعل شيئا عن السعوديه نفس الشيء يعني
نفس الشيء مع بايدن يعني ما فيها الضمانات
من
الواقع ومن يعني المنطقي انه السعوديه
عندما تواجه او او تواجه
حاله انه انه الحليف الامريكي لم ياتي ولم
يدافع وكذا انه يوسع علاقاته استراتيجيه
مع دول اخرى من الصين
بريطانيا منها فرنسا منها روسيا